Welcome, students,
to the Pharmacology
of the DMARDs,
Disease-Modifying
Antirheumatic
Drugs for the
Treatment of
Rheumatoid Arthritis.
And part one of two
parts, I'll give you a
brief overview of the
pathophysiology of
rheumatoid arthritis
as it relates to the
drug therapy. And then
we'll just talk about
two drugs, glucocorticoids
and mesotrexates.
These are both very,
very important,
so I will be spending
time on the mechanisms
and effects and their
place in therapy.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to have a
pharmacology chat.
Learning objectives,
I'm sure you're used
to them by now. We'll
talk about pharmacokinetic
properties,
mechanisms of action,
mechanisms of adverse
effects, mechanisms of
drug interactions, and
all of this, how it
relates to cautions
and contraindications
of their use. I strongly
encourage you to
develop a visual aid
for yourself. Whatever
works, works for you
so that when you are
sitting and reviewing,
you can close your
eyes and kind of visualize
your aid. And same
goes for when you're
sitting in an exam.
Preparation
materials and links,
if you choose
to use them.
And some key
points to get you
into the picture,
to help you
review, however
it helps you.
This is not for
memorizing. This is
for review. This
is for learning.
Lots of drugs,
as you can see,
have been
developed for the
treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis.
Glucocorticoids, I will
be spending time on
this, as I said before,
because they are
really very important in
the relief of inflammation
in patients with
rheumatoid arthritis.
So let's meet a
patient, a 37-year-old
woman who presents
to the rheumatologist
with a six-month
history of joint pain,
stiffness, and swelling,
primarily affecting
her hands and wrists.
her name is Mary.
So pause the computer
and have a read of
this case. I'm not
going to read it to you.
Questions that
it should raise
are, what is the
goal of therapy?
What is the
role of NSAIDs?
We know they're very
good for relieving
inflammation at anti
-inflammatory doses.
and what is the
role of DMARDs and
what is the role
of glucocorticoids.
So let us begin.
Rheumatoid arthritis
is a chronic
systemic inflammatory
disorder that
affects a patient for
their entire lives
and it can negatively
impact the quality
of their life. the
joint problems,
but also manifestations
outside of the
joints. Patients are
fatigued very often.
They may have
nodules. They may have
lung involvement,
heart involvement,
peripheral neuropathy,
vessel involvement,
and hematologic
abnormalities. So the goal
of therapy is going
to depend on the
severity of the disease
and patient factors.
Early, aggressive
pharmacotherapy,
early and aggressive.
You always hear me say
start low, go slow.
This is a case
where we start early
and aggressively
with the purpose of
preventing the joint
damage and disability.
The earlier that
it can be stopped
or at least slowed,
the less joint
damage and disability
that can result.
We often have to
modify the therapy
over time, starting
with probably one
drug and possibly
adding others, possibly
changing therapy,
when appropriate.
As with every
treatment, it must
be individualized
with the object
of getting a
maximal response
with minimal side
effects. These drugs
are powerful and associated
with some serious
side effects. Most
of them are quite
tolerable, but we
always have to keep an
eye on the potential
serious toxicities.
And we can do
that by monitoring
closely and
mitigating them.
Goal of therapy,
remission.
Remission of disease,
if possible. Otherwise,
a low level, low level
of disease activity.
Oops,
physiology.
Well, it's all about
the immune system.
I have some arrows here.
These are targets
of drug therapy, T
cell proliferation,
B cell proliferation.
and clonal expansion,
basic humeral
inflammatory response.
Here we have some
cytokines in here,
TNF-alpha, IL-6, our
important targets.
so it's all about
inflammation and expansion
of the immune system
activation of the
immune system that we
are trying to reduce
the approaches are NSAIDs
just for
symptomatic relief
pain, inflammation,
glucocorticoids,
they're powerful
anti-inflammatories,
non-specific anti
-inflammatory actions.
We use these for a
shorter period of
time because of
the potential for
adverse effects.
And then we have our
conventional
DMARDs, conventional
synthetic, that's
what the S stands for.
Biologic DMARDs,
we're talking about
proteins here, such as
monoclonal antibodies.
And then our small
molecule targeted
drugs, the S again
stands for synthetic.
the armamentarium is
expanding and has expanded
quite rapidly in the
last several years
so I split them up
according to their
subclasses their DMARD
classes and I put
stars on the ones that
are representative
of the group and
frequently used.
These are all oral,
the conventional ones.
These small molecule
ones are oral.
And these have Mab
on the end, So that
tells you they're
monoclonal antibodies,
Mab, and this one
is also injectable.
Bridging therapy for
rapid reduction of
inflammation and relief
of symptoms before
the onset of a fully
effective DMARD
therapy. Well, why
don't we just start with
the DMARD and have
done with it? Well, we
do start with the
DMARD, but it can take
weeks, even months,
for the full anti
-rheumatic effect to be
felt by the patient.
So, just briefly
with NSAIDs, we've
already talked about
this group of drugs.
Minimal, if any,
probably none,
minimal effect on
the progression
of bone and cartilage
destruction.
So we can't put them
in the class of disease
-modifying anti-rheumatic
drugs because they
don't modify the disease.
But they're still
very important in the
management of the pain
and inflammation of
rheumatoid arthritis.
Glucocorticoids.
We try and have as
low dose as possible.
I'll expand on
that dosing strategy
when we get there.
powerful anti-inflammatory
agents that are
highly effective at
relieving the inflammation
associated with
rheumatoid arthritis
and other inflammatory
conditions, not just
rheumatoid arthritis.
Very, very important
group of drugs. So we
use them for bridging
therapy. Well, what
is bridging? Bridging
from the initiation
when the patient is
having this inflammation,
this inflammatory
reaction, causing the
joint destruction,
to the activation, I
should say, to the onset
of fully effective DMARD.
And then we also use
it for acute disease
flares. Patients
with rheumatoid
arthritis even on
therapy can have these
disease flares where
as it just as it says
the disease flares
up it fires up and
glucocorticoids
certain of them can be
injected right into
the joint space and
that can cause some
symptomatic relief
and the great thing
about that That is,
there is very little
systemic exposure
to the intra
-articular injection.
So in general, all
patients diagnosed
with RA should
be started on
DMARD therapy as
soon as possible.
Why?
Start early.
Be aggressive.
The choice of drug,
well, so what do we
initiate? That's going
to depend on what
is the level of the
disease activity.
What comorbidities
does the patient have?
Because these are
important drugs,
they can exacerbate
comorbid conditions.
It also depends
on the stage of
therapy. Is this
initial therapy or
is it a modification
of therapy?
Of course, it
helps patients if
the insurance
company is going
to be able to pay
for the drugs.
Insurance companies
usually don't
pay for every
single drug that was
ever invented for
a given condition.
This should be shared
decision making.
Shared Decision
Making. The patient
needs to be
informed and brought
into the discussion
and involved
in making the
decision on therapy.
And then also,
it's actually kind
of related to the
level of disease
activity is the
presence of signs
associated with
poorer outcome.
So what do we start
with? So usually
a monotherapy and
then escalating up,
increasing the doses
or adding therapy.
I did say early
and aggressive,
talking about the
inflammation. We get
that glucocorticoid
or that NSAID on board
very early. to manage
the inflammation.
And aggressive therapy
for the more
severe cases.
Mesotrexate is the
anchor. I will be using
this term. You will see
this term in literature.
It is the anchor.
An anchor is what
holds the boat to the
floor of the bay. And
methotrexate pretty
much holds the therapy,
rheumatoid arthritis
therapy, to the floor.
Why? Because, one,
improved clinical
outcomes,
sustained maintenance,
generally well
-tolerated, Strong
evidence of
efficacy over many
trials, many years
of experience.
And then we could add
other types of DMARs,
another oral,
conventional DMAR,
biologic, or a small
molecule targeted drug.
These are some
recommendations for pregnancy.
this is really
really important for
you to remember. We
must always remember
what drugs are safe
to give to mother and
fetus during pregnancy.
So I have this
list here. I'd like
you to be aware of
what's considered safe
and what's contraindicated
and the rest fall
in between. So
you only have to
remember these two sides.
Contraindicated,
there are only two.
But why are they
contraindicated?
Because they're
teratogenic,
known teratogenic,
and fetotoxic.
And the pregnancy
can be lost
or the fetus
can be harmed.
so what can can
we use we'll be
talking about
hydroxychloroquine
this is a
conventional oral
sulfasalazine another
azathioprine i'll
get to more detail on
that and most of the
tnf inhibitors at
least up to 32 weeks
so we have some really
good options for the
pregnant patient.
Often though,
during pregnancy,
the disease kind
of remits a bit.
Lactation, again,
I have to just
in conversation
with a pediatrician
to discuss whether
or not it's
appropriate for
the baby to nurse
when the mother
is taking a DMARD.
Pediatrics will, I'm
not going to give
you any examples
of the use of these
drugs for pediatric
patients. That's
a separate issue
all to itself, but
most of these drugs
are utilized for
arthritis in the
pediatric patient.
And geriatric patients,
we have to just
really keep in
mind the comorbid
conditions, the
susceptibility to adverse
effects. They tend
to be more sensitive,
drug interactions,
and organ functions.
This little chart
kind of gives a really
a big picture view
of how to think
about treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis.
This is not a
clinical management
lecture, but we
do need to think
about therapeutic
uses of the drugs
divided into
features with low,
moderate, or high
disease activity,
poor prognosis,
and it's basically
what I just said. Do we
start with the
DMARD monotherapy?
We might have
to start with
combination therapy
if there are
features of a
poor prognosis.
And that's really
basically the concept.
So let's talk
glucocorticoids. I've started
only two, but there are
quite a large number
of synthetic
glucocorticoids available.
On the right, we
see the general
steroid structure.
of cortisol. Cortisol
is the glucocorticoid
that's produced
in the cortex of
the adrenal medulla.
And all of these
glucocorticoid
drugs, synthetic
glucocorticoids, mimic
the actions and effects
of cortisol. cortisol.
What cortisol does,
these drugs do.
The difference is
cortisol is regulated
by its own levels,
feedback inhibition.
These drugs are just
put into the body.
So the glucocorticoid
levels will be related
to the severity of
the adverse effects.
Speaking of
pharmacokinetics,
they are lipophilic.
Steroids are
lipophilic, so they're
well absorbed
from the GI tract.
They do undergo significant
hepatic metabolism,
but enough of that.
The bioavailability
is high enough that
they are effective.
Transported on
plasma proteins,
corticosteroid
binding globulin,
mainly albumin with
the synthetic drugs,
these are saturable.
I'm sure you remember
there are only a
given number of the
plasma proteins
circulating in the blood.
And if there are
high levels of the
glucocorticoid also
attached to the plasma
proteins, then the
amount of free drug is
going to depend on
how much drug has been
administered. The
more drug, the more
saturation of the plasma
proteins, the greater
the free concentration
and vice versa.
I put a star on
prednisone, so
we'll look at that
for the moment.
Most of these synthetics
undergo CYP3A4.
Prednisone so
happens it doesn't.
Prednisone acts
like cortisone
in terms of the
metabolic enzyme.
Cortisone is inactive.
Prednisone is inactive.
They are in
reversible equilibrium
with the active
forms. Cortisol
is the active
form of cortisone.
Prednisolone is the
active form
of prednisone.
And these hydroxysteroid
dehydrogenases
here are responsible for
catalyzing the
conversion between them.
renol, glucuronide, and
sulfate metabolites.
That's the excretion.
Half-life really
varies according to
the particular drug.
Importantly, the
biologic activity lasts
longer than the plasma
half-life because
of the changes that
the drugs cause on gene
expression and
intracellular responses.
Picture here now of
these basic of this
basic physiologic
effect of cortisol and
feedback inhibition
which gets disrupted
when we give the
synthetic glucocorticoids.
this is a figure
illustrating the hpa
axis hypothalamus
anterior pituitary so
p is pituitary to
the adrenal cortex
hypothalamus signals
the pituitary the
pituitary signals
the adrenal cortex
to produce cortisol
cortisol levels
increase as the
cortisol levels increase
It's feedback
inhibition on hair.
And that will lower
the levels of cortisol.
The cortisol comes
out of the adrenal
cortex here. The
adrenals add renal.
They're added to,
they sit on top of
the kidneys. They
have nothing whatever
to do with kidney
function. And the
kidneys have nothing
to do with the adrenal
function other than
possibly signaling
aldosterone to
be secreted. But
that's a conversation
for another time.
Here's cortisol level
in the zona fasciculata.
This is where cortisol
is secreted from.
You probably remember
epinephrine and
norepinephrine come out
of the adrenal medulla.
and the other
corticosteroid here
is aldosterone.
It comes out of
the zonaglomerulosa
mechanism.
I have this
described on the next
slide, but we'll
talk about it here.
Here is cortisol on
corticosteroid binding
globulin, So prednisone
and all of the others
are going to be on
probably albumin
mostly, but also can be
on the corticosteroid
binding globulin. So
we see that together.
Then the steroid
hormone releases
from the albumin,
becomes free, passes
through the cell
membrane, my passive
diffusion, binds
to its receptor.
Now, the receptor
is hanging out
here in the cytosol
on chaperone
proteins, these are
called, heat shock
proteins, that
keep it inactive.
Once cortisol binds,
a steroid binds,
this is a pretty
common mechanism, to
the receptor, changes
the conformation
this complex now
changes the conformation
and the chaperone
proteins leave
the steroid receptor
complex dimerizes passes
into the nucleus binds
to the corticosteroid
binding elements,
response elements,
glucocorticoid response
element, and therefore
affects the expression
of various proteins.
And this is
what it is here.
cortisol effects are
broad and numerous
and the synthetic
glucocorticoids
have the same effects
cortisol is intended
to maintain
metabolic homeostasis
it is important
in carbohydrate
protein lipid
metabolism and
electrical
electrolyte balance
it is important
in cardiovascular
skeletal muscle cns
effects wide wide
effects in the body
it is also important
in suppressing the
immune system so
this is an anti
-inflammatory effects
and it has a
permissive effect on
hormones. I'm not
going to go into
that. But what
this means is it
works together with
other hormones.
Okay, so what does
happen? What are
the anti-inflammatory,
immunomodulatory
effects of all
of the synthetic
glucocorticoids
and cortisol? all.
I've divided this into
actions and effect.
So, glucocorticoids
decrease the number
and activity of
the inflammatory
cells. Okay, so
there aren't as many
around. That'll
reduce the response.
Decrease the movement
of cells from the
circulation into the
tissues. For inflammation
to happen in tissues,
the circulating
immune cells need
to move to the site
of inflammation, and
that gets decreased.
Glucocorticoids
prevent neutrophil
degranulation.
Degranulation spills out
pro-inflammatory
cytokines and
chemokines, and that
calls other inflammatory
mediator. So
that's prevented.
It induces the
movement of circulating
leukocytes into the
lymphoid tissue,
gets them out of
circulation, and they
just sort of hang
out in the lymphoid
tissue. So now there
are a decreased number
of inflammatory
cells by that route.
Reduced B cell
clonal expansion. So
that's going to
reduce the production
of autoantibodies.
which should reduce
the immune attack,
reduces T-cell
proliferation. T-cells
are very important
generals in the
immune response.
So if their
proliferation is reduced,
that's going to
impair the activation
and function of other
immune cells, and
that can also reduce
autoimmune attack.
Inhibit gene
expression of the pro
-inflammatory mediators.
That's part of the
anti-inflammatory
response of cortisol.
So we see decreased
levels of cyclooxygenase
2, which of
course is going to
decrease levels of
the prostaglandins.
Decreased levels of
nitric oxide synthase,
that's important
for basal dilation.
We're going to decrease
levels of cytokines
and chemokines and
other pro-inflammatory
proteins. and induce
gene expression of
the counterbalancing
anti-inflammatory
proteins. So I gave one
example here, lipocortin
A, which suppresses
phospholipase A2.
And suppressing
phospholipase A2 prevents
the release of arachidonic
acid, which prevents
the synthesis of
the prostaglandins,
the leukotrienes, and
other lipoxygenase
products. and other
arachidonic acid products,
which is the reason why
I selected phospholipase
A2 and lipocortin
A as the example.
Therapeutic use now in
rheumatoid arthritis.
Bridging therapy, I
referred to that earlier.
Here, for rheumatoid
arthritis, we use
oral prednisone,
absolutely the most often,
probably 99% of the
time, or 90% at least.
The dosing is
based on clinical
experience and
patient response.
So based on the
rheumatologist clinical
experience, the dose will
be prescribed and then
the patient will be
observed for response.
So that is usually
starting with a high
dose to rapidly decrease
the inflammation
and then tapered to a
lower maintenance dose.
The goal is the
lowest effective dose,
hopefully in the
neighborhood of cortisol,
natural endogenous
cortisol levels.
And then the patient
is maintained on
that low dose for
that bridging time.
And once the DMARD
is fully efficacious,
then the attempt at
withdrawal will be begun,
which is gradually
tapering even this lower
dose to discontinue
the glucocorticoid.
That's the basic idea.
Initiation,
maintenance, withdrawal.
So, okay, it's a great
anti-inflammatory.
Now, glucocorticoid
therapy can slow
the appearance of
new bony erosions,
but it cannot be
used long-term, or
at least we don't
want to use it long
-term, as we do with
the DMARD, because
of its long-term
adverse effects.
Meanwhile,
glucocorticoids are not
curative, and we know
they're not specific
in terms of their
mechanism of action.
I mentioned also
that they could be
injected directly into
the affected joint.
So that's generally
if the patient
has only a few
joints affected.
Also, it's useful for
acute exacerbation,
in other words,
acute inflammation in
selected joints, and
possibly for control
of extra-articular
manifestations.
So
that should have
its own line.
Oral would be
used for that.
Adverse effects
associated with
glucocorticoids.
I've said that
quite a number of
times right now.
The following are
typical toxicities of
prolonged therapy.
and therapy is usually
prolonged. Even the
maintenance bridging
stage is going to
be weeks to months.
Hypertension.
Cortisol itself
causes the blood
pressure to go up.
Glucocorticoids do
and the degree is
going to be dependent
on the dose and the
duration of the
glucocorticoid therapy.
Blood sugar goes up
And when blood sugar
goes up, patients can
experience polyuria,
the need to empty
the bladder very often,
polydipsia, thirst.
First, the fat
metabolism is affected
in which fat can
accumulate in the
center of the body.
In other words,
the abdominal
accumulation of fat.
A buffalo hump, just
like a hump on the
back of a buffalo. So
that's fat accumulation
at the back of the
neck. and moon faces.
The face becomes
round. It
actually has
a moon shape.
Facial skin becomes
red. Skeletal muscle
wasting. So while the
fat is accumulating
in the abdomen
and other places,
the arms and legs can
become quite thin.
The skin becomes
thin and fragile.
It affects
menstruation cycles.
It causes hairiness,
hair to grow.
Acne decreases the
******, can even
lead to impotence
and infertility.
Cataracts with
long-term use.
Increased
intraocular pressure.
Growth retardation
in children.
That said,
it's been found
that when the
glucocorticoid is
removed, the growth can
catch up, but the
idea is to have as
low a dose for a
shorter duration
as possible,
especially in children.
It affects the
bones, bone density,
osteoporosis can
occur, fractures,
necrosis of the femoral
head it's got quite
an effect in the cns
some patients feel
amazing other patients
feel really depressed
and it can even lead
to psychosis and it can
cause headache increased
risk of infection
of course it's an
immunosuppressant impaired
wound healing and
like NSAIDs it is
associated with ulcer
formation, peptic ulcers.
The greater the
cumulative dose, the more
likely to cause chronic
adverse effects.
A little picture to
illustrate all of the
various effects that
we talked about,
and these are called
Cushingoid effects.
Cushing disease
is a disease of
hypercortisolism,
too much cortisol.
And too much cortisol,
Cushing disease,
can be caused by
tumors, for example.
Well, now we're
causing those
same effects by
our drug therapy.
So hopefully this picture
will help you visualize.
And I also have
pictures of real people
here. we see the fat
accumulation in the
belly we see the thin
skin thin fragile skin
here we see the striae
or stretch marks
now talking about the
hpa axis again i brought
this figure here
complications of abrupt
corticoid glucocorticoid
withdrawal acute
adrenal insufficiency,
hence the HPA axis.
The glucocorticoids
act like cortisol,
causing negative
feedback on
production and
secretion of cortisol.
Well, if the
glucocorticoid
is abruptly withdrawn,
the adrenals have,
meanwhile, over time,
shrunken and they are
not able to quickly
respond to that
deficit of cortisol
or glucocorticoid
and therefore they
can go into acute
adrenal insufficiency.
These are the symptoms
severe abdominal
pains vomiting diarrhea
profound muscle
weakness fatigue
hypotension, hyponatremia,
hyperkalemia, even
shock and death.
There is a disease
of hypocortisolism.
It's called
Addison's disease and
these are symptoms
that one would see in
hypocortisolism of
Addison's disease.
Well how do
we manage that
gradually taper the dose.
So over time,
depending on how long
the patient's been
on the drug, it may
have to be tapered
over many weeks.
Another potential
adverse effect of abrupt
glucocorticoid
withdrawal is flaring of
the disease. So the
disease could just
flare up again with
worsening or new
symptoms or increased
disease activity.
So we're going
backwards a little bit.
Down here I just put
the mechanism of the
acute adrenal insufficiency
if you'd like to
understand that.
This is a little mnemonic
I found on Wikipedia.
You can use it if it
helps you. You can
make your own if you
like or not use it.
So let's do a little
knowledge check
here. I invite you to
pause your video and
look at these questions
and see if you
can answer them
without looking back.
So I'll give
you a moment.
Okay, I'll go over the
answers now with you.
What is the goal of
therapy in rheumatoid
arthritis? To achieve
and maintain remission
or a state of low
disease activity, of
course, always without
compromising safety.
What is the role of
NSAIDs in RA management?
To control inflammation
and provide
analgesia. They're
not going to
alter the progression
of the disease.
Naturally, we have
to think about
patients' comorbidities.
If they have a
peptic ulcer, they
shouldn't be taking
an NSAID. That's
just an example.
Now, we talk about
the anti-inflammatory
dose, and for
ibuprofen, I'm using
that because it's
so commonly used
and available without
a prescription,
400 milligrams,
which is two
tablets every
four to six hours,
is an anti
-inflammatory dose.
so that would be
400 times 6 is 1600
milligrams a day
and 400 times 4
is 2400 milligrams
a day you can
see it's a lot four
times four well
i did the math backwards
but you're good at
math so you can work
it out and you can
see that either way
it's a high dose what is
the role of prednisone
in RA management to
control the
inflammation. Prednisone
and other
glucocorticoids rapidly
reduce inflammatory
synovitis in
patients with
rheumatoid arthritis.
Now Mary indicated
that she doesn't
want to take the
prednisone because it
will make my face
and belly fat and
all those other
effects you mentioned.
So what are the effects
that Mary is describing?
Glucocorticoids
mimic the effects
of cortisol, fat
distribution,
increased appetite,
water retention,
and that entire
list on slide 34.
Let's talk about
the DMARDs now.
Just a brief
introduction, and
then we'll talk
about mesotrexate.
DMARDs are defined
as drugs that
slow the radiographic
progression
of rheumatoid arthritis.
That's the point of
modifying the disease.
DMARDs have minimal
direct nonspecific
anti-inflammatory and
analgesic effects. Not
like the NSAIDs, which
have direct effects
that you know
about. Not like the
glucocorticoids. But
these don't have direct
anti-inflammatory
effects, nonspecific
effects, which we'll
see when we get to it.
The clinical
benefit is usually
delayed for
weeks or months.
The response,
patient's response, is
some clinical
improvement. Most
patients have some
clinical improvement.
It frequently induces
an improvement
in serological
evidence of disease.
That's the whole
point of a DMARD.
And DMARD therapy,
especially in the
early part of the
disease, ******* the
development of bone
erosion. Once those
bones have eroded
in later disease, if
it started, it's
not going to make it
go backwards. It's
not going to cure.
so methotrexate is a
folate analog i put
folate up here folic
acid and it's an anti
-metabolite which
means it blocks folate
metabolism just a couple
of slight differences
And the structure allows
it to be a blocker.
Pharmacokinetics first.
Oral, subcutaneous,
intramuscular,
usually oral.
If larger doses
have to be taken,
it might need
to be injected,
usually
subcutaneously. Lastly,
the absorption
of the drug is
saturable because
it is taken up
by reduced folate
transporters.
And if there's too
much methotrexate
coming at them, the entire
dose of methotrexate
won't be absorbed. So the
bioavailability for that
dose will be decreased.
And therefore, it
has to be injected.
The drugs are given
once weekly, a low dose.
They bind a protein
in the blood. 50%
is bound, 50% free
at the usual doses.
But these have a
narrow therapeutic
window and potential
for toxicities.
So the higher the dose,
or what am I saying? So,
well, yes, the higher
the dose, the proteins
become saturated,
higher free levels.
Thinking now
about the anti
-cancer doses, which
are very high.
The drug penetrates
body fluids, so it
gets right there
where it needs to be.
Sustained
concentrations of
liver and kidney,
so the methotrexate
gets into lots of steels.
And it does concentrate
in liver and
kidney. What are we
thinking? Oh, concentration
in liver and kidney.
I wonder if it
causes hepatotoxicity
and renal toxicity.
Yes, it can.
It does not *********
into the CNS.
And it is a substrate of
these various
transporters.
Because it's
not metabolized.
it's taken up
by proliferating
cells so those
cells that are
making dna and
making puranes
and then once inside
the cell it gets
glutamates put on it and
i've put some red boxes
here around the
glutamate portion so that
you can visualize what
we're talking about
and that the The
methotrexate, like folate,
which is also glutamated,
is active, and it
does not leave the
cell as a glutamate
form. It stays there.
It concentrates there.
So the biologic
half-life is longer
than the plasma half
-life, and then it's
slowly eliminated
from those cells.
uh renal excretion
unchanged drug
so renal um renal
function matters
for the low dose and
plasma half-life is
about three to ten
hours just to remind
you it's a biologic
half-life that
really counts the onset
three to six weeks
And believe it
or not, from
among the
conventionals, this
is a fairly rapid
onset. Well,
what does it do?
It blocks dihydrofolate
reductase.
So that's going
to block the
conversion of folic
acid to reduced
folate, which is
the active form.
And therefore, that's
going to inhibit
the DNA and RNA
synthesis and purine.
metabolism. Thymitylate
synthase inhibition
blocks the formation
of thymitylate and
that's going to impair
DNA synthesis and
repair. So that's
something called anti
-proliferative effects.
If white blood cells
formation of DNA
synthesis and repair
of DNA is blocked it's
not going to be able
to proliferate. So
that's where the anti
-proliferative effects
term comes from.
And this seems to
be the one that's
important for the anti
-inflammatory effect.
Something called
ACAR formal
transferase inhibition.
And I'll go
into more detail
on this on the
next slide.
Now, on the
following slide. This
slide has all of
these acronyms
that are on the
following slide.
Here's our cell.
Methotrexate
enters through
the reduced folate
transporter.
Here's our methotrexate.
And it is converted
to the polyglutamate.
And now the
polyglutamate will block
all of these
different enzymes.
While I'm here, I
want to point out
that this is a
reversible reaction, and
it's mostly going
in this direction,
but methotrexate
polyglutamate can
be converted back
to methotrexate, in
which point it leaves
the cell. Okay.
Here is the dihydrofolate
reductase cycle.
We're blocking that,
folic acid to reduced
folate, and this
whole thing.
Thimethylate synthase,
we're blocking
here, so we're
blocking deoxyuridine
monophosphate to be
turned into deoxythymidine
monophosphate, which
is thimethylate,
and that will block
DNA synthesis.
taking a look now
from this part of the
cycle there is a product
called a car which
has a really long
name which is turned
into this with the
help of this enzyme,
which is ACAR
transformylase.
So this is
getting blocked.
And blocking it then will
cause an
accumulation of ACAR.
And as ACAR increases,
it's going to
block this enzyme
and this enzyme.
adenosine monophosphate
deaminase and
adenosine deaminase so
these blocking these
prevents the conversion
to their other
products and the
result is an increase
in adenosine which goes
into the extracellular
space. We're
going to go to the
next slide now for
see what happens next.
This is the same thing
we were talking about
but it's been put in
a linear look here.
So here's our ACAR.
This is the part
out of the dihydrofolate
reductase cycle
right here. here's
our mesotrexate
blocking ATIC so
ACAR is accumulating
and as it accumulates
it's going to
block adenosine
monophosphate deaminase
and adenosine and
adenosine deaminase.
So those get blocked
and because they
get blocked AMP and
adenosine accumulate
because they are not
now converted back
to their products
in that direction.
So AMP goes out into
the extracellular
space. Adenosine
goes out into the
extracellular space. AMP
is converted to adenosine
out here. And now
adenosine will
activate its receptors.
these squiggles here
represent G-protein
coupled receptors,
A2 and A1, both of them
have anti-inflammatory
and immunomodulatory
effects. So by
activating its receptors,
it leads to
immunosuppression and
anti-inflammatory
effects. So that is the
theory based on quite
a bit of empirical
evidence of the
anti-inflammatory
effects of mesotrexate
in immune diseases.
Okay,
anti-inflammatory
effects. So mesotrexate
suppresses the function
of the neutrophils,
the macrophages,
dendritic cells,
lymphocytes, and
polymorphonucleosides.
The antiproliferative
effects are direct
inhibitory effects
on the proliferation
of all of these
various cells and also
T and B cells,
stimulates opoptosis,
inhibits the pro
-inflammatory cytokines
that are secreted by
these various cells and
are linked to the
rheumatoid, arthritis,
synovitis,
pathophysiology.
So why methotrexate
first line?
So why first
line? I should
say methotrexate here.
So why is methotrexate
a first line DMARD
and anchor in
combination therapies?
Once weekly
dosing, so really
convenient.
It's low dosing.
Proven clinical benefits.
Cardiovascular all
-cause mortality.
Long-term
sustained effects.
Well-understood
toxicity profile.
Okay,
just because drugs
have toxicities doesn't
mean we can't use
them if we need
them. If the benefit
outweighs the risk,
we just have to be
closely monitoring.
Methotrexate can be
used in combination
with other rheumatoid
arthritis agents.
It's approved for
use in children's
arthritis, and it's
got a whole bunch
of other uses,
including cancer.
That's what it
was originally
developed for, was
cancer, leukemia.
Okay,
adverse effects. So
what's going
on with this?
GI toxicity.
All of these effects
are going to be
related to rapidly
proliferating body
cells. proliferating
cells, like in the
GI, like the mucosa
in the GI. So
gastrointestinal toxicity,
and that includes
toxicity in the
mouth, stomatitis.
So mucositis, that's
called what I just
described, and inflammation
of the mucous membranes
in the mouth is just
called stomatitis.
And stomatitis may
be the first symptom
that a person
will develop on
methotrexate toxicity.
That's kind of
a harbinger of the
other toxicities.
Hepatotoxicity,
we referred to
that before. Bone
marrow toxicity.
kidney can cause i
said it's used to
treat cancer but a lot
of cancer treatments
can cause cancer
and a lot of immune
suppressants most
of the powerful
immune suppressants
can cause lymphomas
pneumonitis so that's
pulmonary or lung
inflammation skin
inflammation loss of hair
phototoxicity infections
immunosuppressants
increase the patient's
risk for infection
infertility menstrual
irregularities drug
interactions i put
this in red and bold
absolutely contraindicated
absolutely absolutely
contraindicated in
pregnancy in fact
methotrexate is used
for ectopic pregnancy
all patients all
patients folic acid
daily supplementation
is given to reduce
the gi bone marrow
suppression and liver
function test
abnormalities so folic acid
really can be
helpful in mitigating
some of these toxicities
and it does not
reduce the efficacy
of the methotrexate.
Talking about folic
acid supplementation,
folic acid is also
known as vitamin B9,
and when taken daily
at one milligram per
day, it can replete
the folate stores in
patients who take this
low dose methotrexate
chronically. And if
the folic acid isn't
quite doing it, then
there's something
called leucovorin,
which is a reduced form
of folic acid. And
there's a picture here.
This is folic acid.
This is reduced
folic acid.
Oh, I got the arrow
in the wrong place.
So leucovorin is
a form of reduced
folate. It gets
converted into,
well, we see
it right here.
And it therefore
bypasses the block, the
dihydrofolate retugtase
block and just replaces
the reduced folate,
the active folate.
Okay, drug
interactions. Transport,
plasma protein binding,
and mechanism related.
Transport, we talked
about the transportation,
the transporters that
the methotrexate is
a substrate for. Well,
if we block those,
that's going to
increase methotrexate
concentration simple
as that we've talked
about NSAIDs we've
talked about aspirin
we've talked about
penicillins we've talked
about sulfonamide so
you should remember
those and you should
always remember
probenicid even if
you haven't had it yet
that's a gout drug
and it is designed to
block organic anion
transporters and P
-glycoprotein, cyclosporine
and numerous others.
Plasma protein binding.
So displacement
from plasma
proteins by
salicylate, senatoin,
sulfonamides,
doxycycline,
you've had all
of those too.
Mechanism related.
So this is,
we're thinking
shared toxicities here.
We'll be talking
about laflunamide. so
that's something you
should remember. So
what are we talking
about? Other drugs
that cause hepatotoxicity,
other drugs
that cause bone
marrow toxicity, other
drugs that cause
pulmonary toxicity, etc.
Drugs that have the
same toxicities.
Azathioprine causes
hepatotoxicity.
Immunosuppressants
increase the risk of
infection. Well,
methotrexate is an
immunosuppressant and
And it's used with other
immunosuppressants
to manage rheumatoid
arthritis and other
immune disorders.
So when we put
immunosuppressants together,
that further increases
the infection
risk. And there are
guidelines on which
immunosuppressants can
be put together and which
ones should not be
put together because
of that increased
infection risk. Now live
attenuated vaccines,
well they're live.
So if we give an
immunosuppressant, that's
going to decrease
the immunogenicity
and therefore the
vaccine might be less
effective. And there's
always that potential
risk that sort
of hovers in the
background of infection
from the actual live
virus or the live
bacterium in the
vaccine. Now, their ability
to produce infection
has been attenuated,
but still we
don't want to forget
about the potential.
All right.
Now, Mary was, I
invite you to pause the
video and think about
these questions.
Mary was initiated
on the initial
DMARD of choice.
So what is that?
And what was the
dosing schedule?
it's oral low dose
once weekly mesotrexate
because of the
strong evidence of
effectiveness sustained
response manageable
toxicities improved
quality of life in the
treatment of rheumatoid
arthritis and
others mesotrexate is
referred to the anchor
because it has become
the cornerstone of
rheumatoid arthritis
management and it
can be combined with
other demards so this
is an immunosuppressant
drug that can be
combined with other
immunosuppressants.
Mary is given
information on the
potential side effects
of methotrexate
including the signs
and symptoms of
serious adverse
effects. What are they?
Well, it's usually well
tolerated fortunately.
Common side effects
are stomatitis
so that's the
inflammation of the
mucus in the mouth
and the GI upset.
Patients should be
closely monitored.
Just because it's
low dose doesn't
mean we get
complacent for bone
marrow, liver,
and lung toxicity.
Mary was advised
that daily
supplementation with
a particular vitamin
is important for
reducing some
of the side effects
of the drug.
What is the vitamin?
How does it help?
Well, it's folic acid,
once a day, can reduce
the stomatitis, the
mucositis, the bone
marrow, and liver
function abnormalities.
But it doesn't
reduce the efficacy
of mesotrexate,
thankfully.
Why is it
important that Mary
was asked about
contraception
and plans for
becoming pregnant?
Well, you know that
one. It's fetotoxic.
It's teratogenic
and fetotoxic.
fetotoxic really is
the basket term for all
of the toxicities that
a fetus could suffer
spontaneous abortion
skull spontaneous
abortion is it's
pretty common skull
anomalies facial
dysmorphism cns limb and
cardiac abnormalities
intellectual
impairment exposure in
the second and third
trimesters are
associated with
intrauterine growth
restriction and functional
abnormalities. It's
contraindicated.
What are the
mechanisms of
mesotrexate's
immune-modulating
and anti
-inflammatory effects?
Mesotrexate inhibits
dihydrofolate
reductase, which
inhibits folate activity,
which inhibits
purine synthesis.
Thimetylate
synthase inhibition
reduces DNA synthesis, so
that reduces
proliferation.
Adenosine, so methotrexate
increases levels
of adenosine by inhibiting
ACAR transformylase,
A-T-I-C, and that
leads to accumulation
of ACAR, which
inhibits adenosine
deaminase, AMP deaminase,
which increases
extracellular levels of
adenosine, which acts
on its A2 and A1
receptors, which activates
immunomodulatory and anti
-inflammatory responses.
And that's it
for part one.
I leave the summary
for you to read.
It's everything
we said. It's
everything we started
with. the keys
key points and here
are the answers